um i saw an item from matt schneiden of
the athletic i wrote something about it
this morning just before the show it
really encapsulates in my view what the
packers are thinking i was told last
week they're still not budging they're
still not budging they're not budging
when it comes to rogers wanting a trade
and it's very simple their calling is
bluff that's kind of what schneiderman
is saying not kind of it is what he's
saying they don't believe he's never
going to play for them again so they're
not going to trade him they think when
push comes to shove he's going to show
up and when he says things last week
like i love my teammates i love my
coaches i love the fans yeah that
doesn't make the packers think he's not
showing up ever again so until he can
convince them
he's not showing up
there's no reason for them to consider a
trade which means this has to play out
chris and if i'm the packers at this
point whatever i get for him is going to
be 20 22 trade assets anyway yeah why
not let this play out so what okay he
sits out the whole year we'll trade him
after the season when maybe we can get
seven or eight teams to the table
instead of the broncos and maybe the
raiders
i mean no doubt i mean yes
if they wait till after the year
yeah and it's known
and everybody is aware that he's you
know being shopped then you're you're
right i mean there's gonna be
you know a pillage as far as you know
people fighting for that and doing that
so that would increase the the trade
market there's no question about that
and i agree with the packers you know i
think this is something we've been
saying all along it's a guy in aaron
rodgers that's too self-aware he's too
good right now he's too legacy aware the
team's too good all of those things
point to like i just don't think aaron
rodgers will sit out either first off i
think it'd be stupid i mean you only got
one shot at this whole thing you're
coming to the end why waste a year
right now yeah green bay screwed you
over i don't know what else to say they
screwed you over it was a stupid move
and how they handled it and everything
there's no doubt but i i i don't think
he'll sit out i really don't now
what i would say to him now is cause
like it has gone too far if you if he if
he asks my opinion i just go come back
play be awesome like you were last year
have that chip on your shoulder whatever
it is
and
don't be afraid to be make the
organization squirmy the whole year you
got no issues with the coaches the
players have a press conference want to
say some things that are derogatory
towards the front office and how you're
not going to be here and you don't want
to ever play for those guys that'll help
get you out of town too the way you want
to at least at the end of the year maybe
expedite things as well
yeah and look he could come back and
have another fantastic season causing
the packers to say well we're just going
to do this all over again and we'll
bring him back in 2022. at some point
between now and march he's got to make
it he's got to go i'm done right done
right that's it that's the only way
that he's going to have
the packers attention he's got to
convince them and maybe part of
convincing them that he means it after
this year is to be you know that guy
that always has the front office on edge
and it might have to be right brian
goodwoods don't get near the practice
field and if you do wear a cup
wear two cups wear a helmet too and
other protections yes don't get near
this guy this year um so uh highly
unlikely
the packers will trade him
but very likely that there's gonna be
some additional drama and intrigue
starting with whether or not he shows up
for training camp
later this summer unofficially which
began yesterday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports